[Musique]
c'est le légume emblématique du cirque
de salazie le chouchou pousse ici
partout dans les cours
à flanc de montagne et particulièrement
dans les champs serre dues aux victoires
et agriculteurs à mare à poule d'eau et
sur quatre hectares d'exploitations il
produit chaque année 250 à 300 tonnes de
choux choux bio touche aujourd'hui à
salazie mais dirait quasiment tous les
agriculteurs étant agriculteurs sur
salazie toutes les boucles ne lâchera le
morceau de treilles même cueilli fait de
l'élevage qu'il fait autre chose mais il
a toujours du produit que 95% des
agriculteurs sarrasine à montreuil du
jour ne peut pas être agressif et c'est
pour ça dans les eaux sales asie
notamment le show et nous narguent l'onu
nana le climat il faut bien plus qu'un
légume le chouchou fait partie du
patrimoine de ce cirque
si bien qu'une fête lui est consacrée
chaque année et pour cette 14e édition
de la fête du chouchou producteurs
transformateurs et forains se retrouve à
hell-bourg
le public pourra découvrir ici le
chouchou dans tous ses états et là sur
les spawns 1 à 4 modèles de confiture et
repart y était le chouchou nature chaud
chaud cacao show gingembre et le
chouchou pimenter la chose
les 12 13 et 14 mai salazie hell-bourg
fait le chouchou
l'entrée est gratuite pour découvrir
tout le savoir faire des agriculteurs et
les produits du terroir représente quand
même la vitrine du savoir-faire d'abord
agricole de salazie qui est un des
jardins un des greniers de la réunion
comme d'autres grenier dans d'autres
régions de la réunion mais on est quand
même premier producteur porcin premier
producteur de volailles premier
producteur de chevaux puisque c'est la
fête du chou premier producteur de
cresson et on a encore d'autres atouts à
notre palmarès mais aussi c'est tout
l'artisanat qu'il ya autour de cette
fête du chouchou bien sur l'a13 mais
aussi les gâteaux l'art culinaire et
c'est tout cela que nous voulons mettre
en avant dans sa tête de chou
aussi le lieu où est ben on vient
rencontrer l'agriculteur il veut aussi
comprendre sa vie je pense que si tu
fais du terroir on va parler pressage
qui savent le chou champagne dessous
chauvin tous les dérivés de chouchou
aujourd'hui son est à l'honneur et
surtout madame et monsieur l'agriculteur
madame et monsieur qui vivent sur un
territoire où ils ont besoin
le l'agriculture et l'agriculture a
besoin d'eux pour donner aux autres
énergies
[Musique]